good day my name is Caroline apotheon
I'm the director of the nutrition and
weight management Center at Boston
Medical Center and I'm a professor of
medicine at Boston University School of
Medicine and today we're going to talk
about obesity why we're unable to lose
weight and keep it off in this
environment and all of the research over
the past 20 years that have helped us
realize that obesity is a disease and
it's a disease chiefly because of the
connections between the gut and the
brain before I move move ahead I want to
remind you that if you have any
questions throughout the broadcast
please do submit them and I will answer
them after the webinar is over in the
last few minutes so as I just said
obesity is now known to be a chronic
disease has a very complicated etiology
and this slide really depicts probably
of just a partial listing of the
interrelated factors that cause obesity
so we first want to talk about genetics
it is certainly the case that that what
genes you end up with have a lot to do
with your predisposition to developing
obesity in the right environment not
only do your genetics have a lot to do
with it
but the interaction between your genes
and the environment which we call
epigenetics and there are single jeune
gene mutations that certainly cause
obesity they're rare however one of
these mutations is the mutation in the
leptin leptin gene such that there are a
few families around the world that have
this leptin single gene mutation and
giving back leptin which I'll talk about
shortly does get these people to lose
weight but in
the general sort of garden-variety
obesity you have many genes that that
are in play and not a single gene
mutation we also have a lot of
environmental and behavioral factors
that have that have caused an increase
in the predisposition to gain weight
certainly our diet so our diet
especially in the United States but
elsewhere also is very high in fat and
calories there's a lot of fast food
available so we don't have to expend too
much energy to get 3,000 calories in a
meal for example we can just roll down
will not even roll down our window
anymore at the fast food place but push
a button and get 3,000 calories in two
minutes inactivity we don't do as much
physical activity as we used to because
of Technology emotional factors there
you know depression and anxiety can lead
to overeating lack of sleep a lot of
studies have shown that short sleep 6
hours or less a night altergott hormones
so that you end up eating more which
we'll talk about smoking cessation
people who smoked or used to smoke
enjoyed a higher metabolic rate however
when when when you stop smoking you
don't you don't have that higher
metabolic rate and you start to if you
eat the same way you did or even overeat
because you're not smoking you can gain
weight the environmental factors
socioeconomic status certainly has a lot
to do with obesity to lower the
socioeconomic status the more the
predisposition to being overweight
chiefly because of the foods that you
have available access and affordability
of food for example but also the built
physical environment so if you live in a
very urban area as opposed to rural you
may not have access to parks and
sidewalks stress different cultures
socio cultural attitudes revolving
around food have
a lot to do with our interaction with
the built environment and and the
current availability of food and there's
this thing called endocrine disrupters
these are non-food items that are in the
foods that we eat chiefly preservatives
and fertilizers and things to make food
last longer that can at least in the
petri dish
have been shown to predispose one to to
metabolize fat differently and maybe
store fat instead of burn it for example
and then the gut microbiota we have many
there's a lot of research suggesting
that the types of bacteria in our gut
have a lot to do with what we absorb and
what we don't absorb there's not enough
time to talk about all these factors
there are medical conditions leading to
obesity such as polycystic ovarian
syndrome Cushing's syndrome
hypothyroidism medications there are
many medications that predisposed to
weight gain antipsychotics insulin
sulfonylureas steroids are just some of
the examples of medications that can
predispose to weight gain and you need
to know about them in order to help your
patient post pregnancy weight retention
is certainly very common as well and
aging the aging leads to muscle loss and
the muscle loss of course leads to less
physical activity and predispose
predisposition to to to a store fat and
then we're going to talk a lot about
altered homeostatic and reward system
pathways that so the brain has an area
in the hypothalamus which is called
which is it controls appetite and
satiety and pathways leading from the
gut fat tissue and the pancreas can can
either activate or deactivate that
system leading to appetite or satiety
increased appetite or increase satiety
and we have some evidence that some
alterations and disruptions in these
pathways can lead to obesity and then
these disruptions can also alter the
level of hormones and GI peptides that
that this area sees and then we also see
that we can we can create a new body
setpoint in people with obesity by by
surgery by the gastric bypass which
alters levels of hormones and GI
peptides seen by the gut and by the
brain and we'll talk about those so
obesity is a disease we have now ace has
created a complication centric model for
the care of the overweight obese patient
to take into account treatment of this
disease so this is this is on the web
this has been published and endocrine
practice and you can look this up and
see that the first step would be an
evaluation of what kind of other
diseases does that patient have are they
metabolically healthy or metabolically
unhealthy if they're unhealthy do they
have cardio metabolic disease or
biomechanical complications of obesity
such as osteoarthritis for example would
be considered a biomechanical
complication whether or not they have
either of these you still need to treat
and step two would be selection of the
treatment modality after you assess for
complications and notice that that there
is lifestyle modification there is also
MD Rd counseling medical therapy and the
types of therapies on the right and then
there's also surgical therapy if it's
indicated if the patient's BMI is over
35 where the comorbidity we will talk
about these therapies so let's first
talk about the physiology
of energy expenditure energy or
homeostasis is something that the body
tries desperately to find so body weight
is tightly regulated and the body likes
to be at a certain body weight that's
why you get hungry when your body needs
calories and you get full when your body
is satiated and the whole thing revolves
around keeping your body at a certain
body weight if you increase on the right
here if you increase energy intake by
ingestion of proteins fat and
carbohydrates you will increase your
body weight if you decrease it you will
decrease your body weight because your
energy expenditure if you increase your
calories you'll gain weight if you
decrease your calories you lose weight
and the body if you increase your
calories the body will respond by trying
to increase your energy expenditure so
that you maintain a body setpoint
certainly if you keep increasing your
energy intake the body will lose and you
will gain weight but there is a certain
physiology that is in play to keep your
body weight where it is we'll talk about
that further brown fat has been
discovered recently to be to be present
in adults and not just babies and in
animals we know that there's a lot of
brown fat in animals it has a lot to do
with thermogenesis brown fat is distinct
from white tissue white fat because it
produces heat which in animals protects
mammals from hypothermia and the way it
does that is to have a proton
transporter which uncouples
mitochondrial respiration releasing
energy as heat so it's kind of good to
have if you are interested in burning
calories because
uncouples respiration and creates a
futile cycle where you just the energy
that you take in is released as heat so
heat production certainly occurs in
response to cold environments and in
adult humans and in babies and in eating
high fat food so when you eat high fat
food and and which has a lot of calories
you start to activate brown fat and burn
off those calories but if you continue
to do that you will gain weight and it
has been thought that a defective UCP
action could be linked to the
development of obesity so here is brown
and white fat how they're different they
are different because this is brown fat
you can see it's full of mitochondria
compared to white fat which stores fat
in the middle here and so the nuclei are
pushed out to the side and brown fat is
smaller than white fat and the energy
that is released as heat whereas in
white fat you store the fat Brown fat
prevalent so how much brown fat you have
has to do with your your age and your
body mass index as is shown here the
older you are the less brown fat you
have and the bigger you are the more the
higher your BMI the less brown fat you
have as well generating the question is
it the lack of brown fat that causes
obesity or maybe a dysfunction of brown
fat what's causing the obesity here
which came first the chicken or the egg
this is how you can visualize brown fat
by pet/ct and that's how we discovered
actually a researchers discovered that
you that there is brown fat in humans so
the brown fat really is prevalent in the
sub clavicular area here this is all
brown fat and you can you can actually
measure brown fat this way but it's
pretty expensive to do so so it's just
used in research right now now depending
on your brown fat activity level when so
this is a study in overfeeding when you
overfeed someone your 24 hour energy
expenditure increases and obviously so
does your so does your your mass your
your weight and depending on the person
and how much brown fat you have the
increase in energy and the increase in
in your way can be a certain percentage
of a certain percentage of fat free mass
and a certain percentage of fat mass so
it depends on the person is so these are
five different subjects and you can see
they all gain weight good because
they're being overfed but it depends on
the subject what is a fat and what is
lean mass so let's integrate this a
little bit let's go and now talk about
the hypothalamus and the integration of
peripheral and central signals so as I
said before there are the CNS has
systems that called the homeostatic
system and the reward system that takes
in signals from the periphery so these
what are these peripheral signals these
signals one is insulin one is leptin we
also have ghrelin pyy
insulin comes from the pancreas as you
know insulin is secreted from the
pancreas to take care of your blood
sugar and insulin also enters the brain
and enters the homeostatic system which
is in the hypothalamus and causes
satiety leptin does the same thing but
leptin is a more long-term signal coming
from fat tissue leptin is secreted from
fat tissue at a homeostatic level and
changes in leptin occur when you for
example you lose fat because you're on a
diet when you lose fat you're on a diet
you less leptin goes to the brain
because let's let them secrete from fat
tissue and eventually you get hungry
because less leptin is causing satiety
until you regain that fat mass that's
why it's a homeostatic signal ghrelin is
a more short-term signal from the
stomach right before you eat - and it's
the only hunger hormone that we know the
others cause satiety ghrelin causes
hunger pyy is secreted from the small
intestine when you generated enough food
ingestion through the intestine and
those cells secrete pyy which go to the
brain and cause satiety those are some
of the examples of peripheral signals so
these systems regulate appetite energy
expenditure and also reward so there's a
reward system which can override the
homeostatic pathway that I just talked
about so it and and this happens in
periods of energy abundance because you
know after all usually when you eat
dinner your full homeostatic system
causes satiety but when the chocolate
cake comes out or the ice cream you
you're still you still got the desire to
eat the ice cream and that's the reward
system working so you have these two
pathways the reward system can override
the homeostatic system
okay and the reward system feeds the
feeds from other parts of the brain to
get you to keep eating even though
you're full homeostatic Li or full so
there's the hypothalamus the regulation
center of am appetite and energy and the
peripheral signals to the hypothalamus
come from areas of the body including
fat tissues secreting leptin you've got
the intestine some stomach secretes
ghrelin insulin comes from the pancreas
you've got the small intestine secreting
pyy here and glp-1 and ox anthe module
and two others that cause satiety as
well they all get integrated in the
hypothalamus to regulate your body
weight notice that we only know one
appetite stimulating hormone which is
ghrelin okay the brain systems receive
those signals and the peripheral systems
send them alright I just want to make
one other point the vagus nerve here is
also receiving it's these these signals
go to the going to the bloodstream but
some are also directly directly go to
the brain via the vagus nerve also so we
have redundant systems here and the
vagus is also a system that can be
regulated so you've got your energy
balance if you restrict by clerk
restricting fasting or exercise you get
negative energy balance if you overfeed
high-fat diet and you're sedentary you
get positive energy balance and you end
up gaining weight so again just an
overview of all the gut hormones we just
talked about pyy pancreatic polypeptide
glp-1 ox an
demodulate these are sopretty suppress
appetite and they come from the gut the
only one that increases appetite is
ghrelin and these are modulated by acute
food ingestion however you've got short
and long-term energy homeostasis through
leptin which comes from fat tissue and
insulin that comes from the pancreas
another summary notice that all of these
hormones have other actions
besides appetite and satiety regulation
so for example pyy delays gastric
emptying glp-1 decreases blood glucose
so you've got dual actions for some of
these gut hormones now the interesting
part is is that why are we all open why
are we developing obesity why do some of
us develop some of us develop obesity at
a young age others at an older age so
obesity it looks as if is it's
associated with hypothalamic injury at
least in rodents and some suggestion
that this is true in humans so there are
rodent models of obesity that consume a
high-fat diet
and researchers have found that not only
do you get inflammation in the fat and
peripheral fat tissues but in the
hypothalamic areas that are critical for
energy homeostasis hypothalamic inflam
inflammatory signaling was evident in
rats and mice within one to three days
of high-fat diet
onset prior to gaining a lot of weight
in these animals so this was kind of a
breakthrough that maybe it's a
disruption of the appetite and satiety
pathways that are doing this so what
what they found in pathology is that you
saw reactive Klee osis and markers
suggested them suggest suggesting
neuronal injury
in this hypothalamic area of appetites
is hiding rats and mice within the first
week of high fat feeding and then these
researchers then thought to look at MRIs
of obese humans and found evidence of
increased gliosis in the hypothalamus of
obese humans what does this mean these
suggests the suggestion that obesity is
associated with neuronal injury in the
brain crucial in the area crucial for
body weight control in animals and
rodents so meaning what does this mean
it means that perhaps if you eat a high
fat diet or a lot of calories especially
when you're young and you continue to do
so
if it's if this is true that it happens
in humans you get this hypothalamic
inflammation would causes a disruption
of the appetite satiety signals and you
no longer are aware that you're full
because yours
the signals aren't getting to the brain
and you keep eating that's that's that
that needs to be really confirmed in
humans the suggestion is there but it's
certainly true in animals very
interesting so why can't people use lose
weight I just really it's why can't
people keep the weight off I just told
you that the research is out there
suggesting why but let's look at the
studies so this study was published a
few years ago looking at three different
diets low fat Mediterranean low carb
patient dieters lost weight within the
first six months or so and then when the
dieting stopped and patients were
allowed to eat whatever they wanted they
did regain weight and it didn't matter
the glice you know the the the type of
macronutrients in the diet didn't matter
everyone gained weight everyone lost
weight so this is called the fat trap
why people regain weight basically
you've got the genetic developmental
factors however there's inflammation and
neuronal injury in addition to the
increase in calories from the diet that
create the situation where you keep
eating and the satiation signals aren't
getting to the brain so again you're
eating a high fat high carb food diet
the typical types of food that that are
very prevalent in the society and
certainly in low socioeconomic
backgrounds you get CNS insulin and
leptin resistance because of this dis
disruption of neuronal pathways and
insulin leptin are not producing satiety
the brain cannot tell how much fat is
stored you get this reduced sense of
satiety and craving increased weight
gain and you get this feed-forward
it's a feed-forward phenomenon a
feed-forward phenomenon keep eating
that's what happens so the fat trap
another another study showed in these
dieters getting in very low calories 500
550 calories a day at 10 weeks there was
a 30 pounds average weight loss at year
one at year 1 after the dieting which
was 10 weeks long patients gain on
average about 11 pounds and the point
here is that patients reported feeling
hungry with more hungry and preoccupied
with food than before the weight loss
here is what this looks like
so you have patients losing weight ten
weeks and then regaining weight 11 pound
weight gain and they measured the
hormones I was just talking about and
found leptin reduction at the end of a
year pyy reduction CCK reduction insulin
reduction and amylin reductions all of
the appetite the appetite the satiety
producing hormones were reduced and
guess what ghrelin the only hunger
hormone that we know was increased and
also measures of appetite showed a lot
of increase in appetite 14% weight loss
produced changes in ate hormones that
encouraged weight regain so and this is
what it looks like
ghrelin levels were increased pyy
decreased CCK decrease enamel and
decrease hunger increased and desire to
eat increased as well and so these
changes in hunger and the desire to eat
produce that weight regain in addition
to this so this is all evidence that
it's very difficult for us to keep the
weight off when we lose weight because
of these gut hormones studies were done
looking at resting energy expenditure
and resting energy expenditure decrease
in resting energy expenditure is found
to be a determinant of weight regain in
a series of long-term dietary
interventions so 90 publications showed
that you you get a decrease in your
resting energy expenditure when you lose
weight and what's the what kind of a
decrease in energy expenditure well
after a review of lots of publications
roughly 15 calories per kilogram of body
weight loss so every time you lose a
kilogram your resting energy rate
decreases by 15 calories so in other
words if you lose
kilograms you you get to eat 150
calories less per day very difficult to
do in this environment so again just to
just to summarize all of these key
hormones either suppress appetite or
increase appetite actually the only one
we know that increases is ghrelin and
these are key hormones that are
associated with weight gain and regain
after losing weight I want to mention
one more thing which is another hormone
that comes from muscle our reason was
discovered a few years ago it's secreted
from muscle into the blood and activates
what does it activate it activates white
fat and turns it into brown fat all
right so I recent acts on white adipose
cells and culture at least and in vivo
to stimulate UCP one expression and a
program of brown fat like development so
how do you increase a riesen you
exercise I recent is induced with
exercise and mice and humans and
increase our recent levels and blood
causes increase in energy expenditure in
mice with no changes in movement or food
intake resulting in improvements in B
cities so the bottom line is I recent
could be therapeutic for human metabolic
disease and other disorders that are
improved with exercise so you want to
increase our recent exercise and you may
be able to keep the weight off and
that's this is like this is like a
breath of fresh air to me it also I a
light bulb went off when I read about
this because now we know why exercise is
so important in a preventing weight
regain in those who have lost weight
maybe due to my recent so here's here's
a schematic showing that I recent is
produced during exercise Arisa is
produced causing a Browning of white
adipose tissue
enriched with brown out of the sights
that produce you see p1 and increase
your resting metabolic rate so these are
all these are all begged the question
for how we can help people lose weight
if we have this hypothalamic
inflammation if we also have
determinants of browning of white fat
white fat which with with I recent
projects err sighs what does that mean
for new therapeutic options for helping
people lose weight and more most
importantly keeping the weight off well
we have anti-obesity medications there
are many that have been researched a few
are out there that have been
fda-approved when do we use them we use
them for patients who have tried diet
and exercise for at least six months and
behavioral change because that's the
core you know if you can if you can
change the way you're eating eat more
fruits and vegetables more whole grains
and more protein and stop eating fast
food maybe that will be all you need but
if it's not pharmacotherapy can be used
for patients with a BMI over 30 or over
27 with at least another disease like
hypertension dyslipidemia heart disease
diabetes or sleep apnea that's how you
use these drugs
what are approved so we have a new agent
approved since July 2012 it's called
Hugh Samia which is a combination of a
little bit of fent amine and a little
bit of topiramate
they both they both can help you lose
weight but the combination has shown
less side effects than either alone and
that's why they've they've combined them
to produce cue Samia phentermine is an
ore adrenaline and dopamine releasing
agent appear mate is an anticonvulsant
and has gaba modulator properties some
of the side effects are listed here not
too bad dry mouth tingling constipation
alter taste upper respiratory infection
I don't think so
Laura Catherine another approved another
drug approved on June 2012 it's called
bell Veeck brand name selectively
targets the five h2c receptor producing
satiety both of these produce satiety in
different parts of the hypothalamus side
effects headache dizziness nausea why do
we say it's selectively targets the
5-htt to see receptor because it's the a
and B it was the B receptor that caused
valve you lop ethey with the old fen
phen the fen floor amine and built and
Redux years ago there are many in
developments so if you remember me
talking about glp-1 and ox ante module
in glp-1 agents are already out there
for diabetes this one lure a glow tide
is being looked at as an obesity agent
but we also have pancreatic polypeptide
and amylin being looked at for their in
Phase three trials for obesity some
leptin analogs and others that are not
quite ready yet so what are the
mechanisms of action of some of the
obesity agents well phentermine which
has been around for a long time now it's
it's it is in the combination fen taupe
which is Ksenia increases narbon Orban
epinephrine levels in the hypothalamus
and causes a sympathetic response that
causes satiety sigh butte Ramin which is
an old drug it's now d it's been taken
off the market for increase in stroke
but it was a rillette trance
order of 5-ht and norepinephrine and it
caused satiety in the hypothalamus
ramana band also has never approved so I
won't talk about about it the only one
that works outside of the hypothalamus
currently is orlistat which is a lie or
xenical works in the gut to mal absorb
about 30% of fat calories other
molecular targets we can talk about
topiramate here which works on gaba and
the combination of topiramate and
phentermine produces good weight loss
with less side effects than either alone
you have low Katharine working over here
so here's the center of appetite and
satiety right here and here's where some
of these agents work there are two
neuronal pathways here one produces when
stimulated causes an increase in
appetite the other an increase in
satiety and they all sit within the
hypothalamus and here's where some of
these drugs work so pram low tide which
is a M'Lynn works peripherally here and
then and then works on some of these
targets later on where some like Laura
Catherine work directly in this
hypothalamic area very very complicated
as you can see and some of these are
already out some of them are being
looked at the ones that have numbers
obviously are in research so what are
other strategies to develop these
anti-obesity drugs so there are those
that work in the hypothalamus but in the
future we need those that work through
modulating exercise so for example maybe
i recent i recent analogs can do what
exercise Doug's the exercise Doug does
to brown white fat tissue
for example so you've got to somehow in
decrease sedentariness and increase
exercise we have caloric restriction
that occurs with the appetite
suppressants currently and so the future
will combine Behavioral Interventions
with these drug therapies to push the
envelope on weight loss and more
importantly weight maintenance so the
future for the targeted drug
interventions again here we have the
appetite and satiety regulating center
in the hypothalamus the two sets of
neurons one increases food a intake the
other decreases food intake and we have
the the hormones that modulate these
this hypothalamus how hypothalamic area
you've got the combination of the higher
mate and phentermine available you've
got Laura Castro novela available pretty
soon we'll have a combination of B Pro
prion and now Trek so available now no
trek stone is an anti addiction agent
the combination of this and this will
causes a synergistic effect the
bupropion works
however the naltrexone blocks the
negative feedback inhibition and so it
works better what you want to do is get
is get combinations of these drugs and
also maybe combinations of these gun
hormones here promote I'd eggs and
toddler aglet I'd which are glp-1
agonists combined with some of these
others to work in several different
areas that is the future now in the
remaining few minutes I'm going to talk
about really the only cure we know for
weight regain which is bariatric surgery
and why is that I will explain why here
are some of the surgical procedures we
have to get the purely restrictive
procedures which is which are the Lap
Band which is
adjustable band that is placed around
the stomach here that hooks on to a port
which is subcutaneous you inject saline
into this port and the balloon here
expands and causes obstruction or a
narrowing of this pouch which produces
satiety you also have the laparoscopic
sleeve gastrectomy which is now known as
more of the malabsorption procedure also
not just a restrictive but you cut part
of the stomach out so here was that
stomach it's thrown out and here is the
sleeve of stomach that's left and the
food goes down this way and as you can
see you have less space for food to
enter and that causes a restriction of
calories but also you also have cut out
some of the cells that produce ghrelin
here so you get satiety from altering
gut for moans as well that's why you get
more weight loss with the sleeve
gastrectomy than the lap-band you also
have a new a new procedure called the
glass the gastric plication where you
involute the stomach as you can see here
you involute the stomach and you end up
with a sleeve just like here without
throwing out and cutting into the
stomach so these are the restrictive
procedures here are the metabolic
procedures we call them now metabolic
procedures and that knot now absorb the
procedures because we're metabolically
altering gut hormones what do I mean by
that with the Ruan why gastric bypass we
create a small pouch here and cut we cut
into this part of the stomach
but this is all bypassed and here's the
new stomach which is very small hooked
on to a piece of jejunum that is brought
up hence we have a small stomach and we
have jejunum in contact much earlier
with food what does that do it alters
some of the hormones that see food and
I'll talk about that later the billy-oh
pancreatic diversion is a different
procedure it's not done in certain
states because it's very very aggressive
whereby you create the sleeve like you
did here
same thing but you also bypass most of
the small intestine you bypass all of
this so what happens with these
procedures well first of all you lose a
lot of weight so here here's the weight
loss in in percent weight loss and here
are years you lose most of your weight
with many of these procedures in the
first year you lose the most weight with
the billy-oh pancreatic diversion and
the gastric bypass so you lose about 33
percent of your total body weight and
you basically keep a lot of that off out
to 20 years with the gastroplasty you
lose a little bit less let you keep it
off the banding is all over the map but
you tend to keep a good part of it off
and here are the controls patients who
are on diet and exercise we have 20 year
data showing good weight loss and good
weight maintenance so why why is this
the only person the only thing that we
know that will keep the weight off here
is the reason and to use to simulate
this I'm just going to use the Rouen Y
gastric bypass because this gives
good weight-loss and west side effects
in the billy-oh pancreatic diversion but
you see this kind of weight loss and
more with the billy-oh pancreatic
diversion so we're creating a small
pouch here here this is bypass this the
rest of this stomach and this part of
the duodenum is bypassed plus you're
hooking up a piece of jejunum to the new
stomach so what happens is you have
bypassed the area of the stomach that
produces ghrelin and remember ghrelin
causes an increase in appetite gone the
other thing you do is the cells that
produce some of the appetite satiety
hormones like pyy and glp-1 see food
much earlier so what happens is you get
full much earlier and that is why we
think that the we think that this
procedure here the roux-en- y gastric
by-pass not only helps you lose weight
through restriction here but helps you
keep it off because you you just don't
your levels of pyy and glp-1 go up and
your levels of ghrelin go down and this
is basically permanent so your body's
setpoint alters permanently do you lose
down to a normal body weight no you lose
about 100 to 150 pounds so if you weigh
400 pounds you're still going to end up
weighing 300 or 250 but your but your
body is set permanently to a lower body
setpoint and this is why it's now called
metabolic surgery and not just
restrictive or malabsorptive surgery
so I just want to summarize I think I've
made a case for obesity being a chronic
disease with a complicated etiology
therefore we need a chronic care model
to help manage overweight and obese
patients why is it a why is obesity as a
disease it is a disease because there
are complicated CNS systems that
regulate appetite energy expenditure in
response to eating and we think these
systems are disrupted
we have complicated peripheral and
central signals they're integrated in
the CNS to regulate body weight on a
very tightly controlled system and the
hypothalamus is the primary regulation
center of appetite satiety and energy
expenditure and remember that there are
ways to alter your energy expenditure
through increasing brown fat through our
recent and exercise so you've got diet
exercise and behavioral interventions
the homeostatic control system and the
reward system bi-directionally interact
to affect food intake so you know if you
if you didn't have desserts available
you would just regulate your energy
intake when you're full you're full but
we've got these enticing desserts out
there and other enticing foods with high
salt that that that triggered the reward
system and you still want to eat that
food even though you're full and that
may be why one of the reasons why it's
so difficult in this highly palatable
food environment to keep a certain a
certain body weight because the reward
system can override the homeostatic
pathway chiefly during periods of
relative energy abundance by increasing
the desire to consume foods that are
highly palpable
I'll think about when we were from Agnon
man we had to go out and kill a deer and
get plants to feed ourselves we were not
we were not worried about the reward
system right we just wanted to feed
ourselves to maintain our survival to
keep survival now we've got all of these
ways of making food more palatable
through technology obviously through
agriculture and technology and but we
still have the genes that we had
yawns ago and so when we see really good
food we want to eat it because our genes
still don't know when our next meal is
going to come from
we have gut hormones act peripherally to
modulate digestion and absorption of
nutrients but they also act as as
neurotransmitters within the CNS to
control food intake alterations and
gutted the gun hormones after weight
loss are not consistent long-term so
what happens is we still these gut
hormones still work to make us regain
that long that lost weight and a better
understanding of the role of gun
hormones may offer an opportunity to
develop more successful treatments for
obesity so the the the treatments that
we have available better drugs can help
us lose about 10 percent of our body
weight with diet and exercise and maybe
in combination we can more closely
simulate the kind of weight loss we can
get with gastric bypass surgery who's
about which is about 30 to 33 percent
weight loss as opposed to 10 percent 10
percent is at its best for drugs
bariatric surgery produces long-term
weight loss and alters permanently the
gut hormones to maintain that weight
loss newer anti-obesity medications may
show promise there are many in the
line the the goal here would be to
simulate what we can do with gastric
bypass surgery so at this point I'm I'm
ready for your questions and I see that
maybe we have some and I'm gonna start
so first question is the neuronal injury
reversible in the animal model that's a
very very good question so in the animal
model it was shown that it is reversible
if you stop high-fat high-calorie
feeding within a week but if you
continued the high-fat feeding beyond
one to two weeks in the animal model it
becomes purr it becomes permanent very
question does that does that prove that
that's the case in humans no we really
need to test this in humans great
question next question has I recent been
tested in animals yes it has and a
recent ested in animals and has been
shown to increase brown fat development
from white fat next question I recent
and exercise does the type of exercise
matter as in weight lifting versus
running that's a very very good question
I don't think this has really been
rigorously tested but it's a very good
question
it seems that that both running and
weight lifting increases metabolic rate
so but to what extent and to what extent
does I recently in we don't really know
very very good question next question is
there a reason why there hasn't been a
drug developed to work directly on
grilling very good question and there is
we are there are ghrelin
a Guinness and antagonists being
researched out there very rigorously so
why would use a ghrelin agonist well
stimulate weight gain and those who are
malnourished or who have a malabsorption
issue and are malnourished and you would
want to grill an antagonist as a
treatment for obesity and that is
certainly being looked at great question
another question could any of the
surgical procedures be done with local
anesthesia another good question the
answer is the ones that I that the ones
that I have shown you the ruined my
gastric bypass the billy-oh pancreatic
the version the the gap the gastric band
and the sleeve are not done under local
because you're really altering you've
got to get into the abdomen there
laparoscopically however a good question
some of the gastric plication the
gastric plication that i showed you
could be done and disco Polly so there
is a procedure called gastric plication
that is done with sutures that are
placed endoscopically so that's being
researched currently great question next
question would it not be simpler to
simply remove the ghrelin producing
aspect of the stomach either surgically
or pharmacological yes and that is
exactly what is done with the gastric
sleeve so you move that large piece of
stomach and create a sleeve so yes that
is bit currently being done and that's
called the gastric sleeve next question
what is your what is your take about
diets that claim to increase leptin or
to address leptin resistance well diets
that claim to increase leptin Hatun
you know how do you increase leptin how
do you address leptin resistance is
really the question so so
you really can't do that by diet so I
really wouldn't believe a diet that
claims to increase leptin that's my
answer
leptin is produced by adipose tissue and
enters the brain and causes satiety
leptin resistance occurs probably from
that hypothalamic injury that I was
talking about the only way to reduce
that leptin resistance is to stop eating
bad food so so if if diets that are that
claim to increase left and/or reduceleft
and resistance do so by eating very
healthy food I agree fruits and
vegetables lean protein and low-fat
dairy that will that will address leptin
resistance next question if the
hypothalamus has a reduced ability to
detect endocrine signals for fullness
after inflammation what then about
ghrelin would it not also become
undetected and thereby prevent the
ability to trigger hunger Hunger if the
hypothalamus has a reduced ability to
detect endocrine signals for fullness
after inflammation what then about
ghrelin would it not also become
undetected and therefore prevent the
ability to trigger hunger hunger good
good point I don't think we have the
answer to that so one thing I would say
is that the vagus also directly ascends
signals via ghrelin and maybe that is
not affected by the hypothalamic obese
inflammation but that's that's a
question that we really that is
complicated we really don't know the all
of the effects on these various signals
by the information excellent question
next question is the inflammatory effect
on the hypothalamus reversible if the
patient switches to a low glycemic
eating habit very good question this is
in humans we really don't know my take
on this is is yes
that if you if you want to reverse the
inflammation you've got to go on a very
very healthy diet switching to low
glycemic index ties which is just really
fruits and vegetables whole grains lean
protein right it's getting rid of the
high sugar high sugar processed foods
and I think you can do it I don't have
proof of that
so that has yet to be researched kindly
comment on the role of the gut microbe
microbiome and obesity digestion of
carbohydrates and the production of
appetite related hormones and
neurotransmitters very very complicated
but yes it looks as if when you do a
gastric bypass beyond all of those
hormones I talked about what you're also
doing is changing that gut microbiome
towards one that is seen in a lean
patient so in in lean versus obese
patients it has been shown that there is
a different percentage of Bacteroides
versus firm acuity from acute ease and
that is reversed with the gastric bypass
and these this gut microbiota has been
shown to produce varying amounts of the
dark hormones that I've just talked
about
in other words that the the society
producing hormones are increased in the
lean microbiome
however there there's a lot more at play
here and it's it's very complicated it
has been shown that yes if you
transplant the lean fecal matter from a
lean mouse to a beast mouse you get
weight loss whether or not we're going
to start doing this in humans is still
up in the air and it's it's just a lot
more complicated than then simply that
then simply fecal transplantation for
example what what role do antibiotics
play what role do antibiotic
in food play these are all complicated
issues that are being researched now
there is a researcher at NYU who who
feels that that it could be that obese
children are obese because they are the
ones that have gotten more antibiotics
in their young life for example for
otitis media and the like we have yet to
study that a very good question and
another question should we begin to
start treating the gut bacteria directly
rather than treating the human patient
indirectly well yes if we if we confirm
that it is indeed the gut bacteria that
is causing obesity and we really don't
know that yet we really need more
research into alterations and gut
microbiome before and after gastric
bypass people are looking at that now we
need to study this more in depth Lee and
the NIH is grappling with how to study
the human gut microbiome as we speak and
so yes it may be that in the future
we'll begin to start treating the gut
bacteria directly rather than treating
human patients indirectly certainly I do
firmly believe that current drugs and
current currently available surgical
options are really the tip of the
iceberg
certainly drugs are getting you know
patients to lose five to ten percent of
their body weight while giving them a
drug that has side effects and and
having to do this permanently to
suppress the appetite giving them drugs
for the rest of their life is not a good
answer to me and but but again we need
to study this first and then we may be
able to treat the gut bacteria directly
as you say it's a very very good
question seized I have to say these are
some of the best questions I've ever
received after one of my talks so I
really thank you for that
and I think unless we have any more
questions
I think the broadcast is over and I
thank you so much for all of your
important and very very very you know
these questions or questions that the
researchers are asking as we speak so
thank you so much for your attention